[Music]
the guardians of the galaxy will finally
be back in action in july three years
after avengers endgame the galaxy's
craziest heroes celebrate the comeback
and thor love and thunder but this shall
not be the end of their cinema career
peter gamora drax rocket groot mantis
and nebular will get their last solo
film in may 2023 for a conclusion only
one year remains until then and there
are already a few rumors surrounding the
cast and the story we have taken a look
at all the facts and theories and then
decided to summarize them for everyone
here so if you're interested keep on
watching
as you can probably guess the movie will
take place after end game following the
victory of a thanos thor joins the
asgardians and seems to take over the
leadership of the team whether the flick
will play at the same time as thor love
and thunder or after it has yet to be
revealed but for us there are two
realistic scenarios in the first the
guardians play only a minor role in the
grand thor finale and must already
devote themselves to more important
missions in the galaxy during the film
and the second option the guardians
movie only begins after the thor
storyline and they find alongside the
god of thunder until the end of course
it will be exciting to see where the
guardian stands story wise towards the
end of thor 4.
there have already been a few
announcements regarding the cast and
which characters will appear in the new
movie they're not only old familiar
faces but also a few newcomers
for the time being not much will change
among the guardians chris pratt will
return to his role as star lord and dave
bautista is set to play drax for one
last time karen gillian paul clementy
van diesel and bradley cooper are also
back as nebular mantis groot and rocket
it will be especially thrilling around
gamora played by zoe zaldana after all
the gamora from the main dimension died
and the one who was brought from the
past neither knows the guardians nor has
he developed a relationship with peter
it has also been confirmed that the
ravagers are coming back at the end of
the last part they bid yondu udonda a
dignified farewell after his heroic
death for this sean gun will slip back
into the role of craglin who knows he
might be in charge of his own ship by
now who definitely has his own crew
though is sylvester stallone as stycar
ogord known in the comics as starhork we
were already able to see him in volume
2. it was him after all who granted
yondu absolution after his death and to
be buried with full honors in space so
far it has not been confirmed whether
there will be flashbacks of yondu and
the currently confirmed cast list at
least michael rooker is not to be found
yet
in the post-credits scene of the last
movie the adversary of volume 3 was also
introduced there the high priestess
ayesha could be seen breeding a new
evolved sovereign named adam this adam
is none other than adam warlock in the
comics he was created by a group of
researchers who wanted to make the
perfect being in the film the role of
adam will be played by will poulter it
is likewise confirmed that elizabeth
debicki will once again slip into the
role of the high priestess ayicha
where the thor will be back for
guardians vol 3 has not yet been
definitely clarified however it is
likely he will appear in at least a few
sequences first this is due to the fact
that he joined the asgardians of the
galaxy at the end of end game and they
will also appear in his solo film love
and thunder second he's the first hero
adam warlock meets on the comics so why
shouldn't he be in the motion picture as
well
it was certainly not easy to get to the
start of filming for the third part of
this series although director james gunn
confirmed back in march 2017 that there
would be a third part the mastermind
behind the guardians first had to pack
his backs after an almost 10 year old
tweet of his was made public in which he
made fun of sexual assault since this
could not be reconciled with the strict
guidelines of disney they felt compelled
to dismiss gun only after more or less
the entire star ensemble of the
guardians had publicly stood up for
their director did they bring gun back
to the project in march 2019 this
allowed production to restart with a
considerable delay the year 2020 was
originally planned as the shooting start
but of course they didn't know
beforehand that everything would turn
out differently that year thus guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 had to be added to
the long list of postponements in
addition chris hemsworth also expressed
interest in shooting a fourth solo film
around his character of thor this
production was then promptly given more
attention filming on the guardians movie
finally began at the end of 2021 and
provided everything run smoothly the
premiere will take place on may 5th 2023
unfortunately not much is known about
the plot so far god himself said in a
podcast that the third and last part of
the guardians will probably the most
somber he also implied that not everyone
in the group will survive their final
battle apart from that there are already
one or two theories about this story
which we shall explore here however we
would like to emphasize once again that
these are pure theories and not
confirmed facts
it is safe to say that the guardians
will look for gamora as he disappeared
after the final battle against thanos
she will probably first need to find her
own place in what is now a completely
new universe for her she could start her
journey on her home planet zen will vary
thanos killed half the population but
there are also many indications that
gamora is the last of her kind from this
point one could also easily form a
connection to the ravagers gamora could
join them in return to see more of the
galaxy and well to pursue her
extraordinary talents and killing there
she could then meet craiglin and
starhawk these will surely cross the
guardian's path sooner or later
as mentioned at the beginning adam
warlock was created in the comics by
researchers from earth immediately after
his awakening he meets thor and is
fought by him after he tries to mate
with lady sith however adam warlock is
not evil but similar to vision a being
was yet to find his place in the
universe this task which he lacked at
the beginning of the comics might
eventually be easily given to him in the
film namely revenge against the
guardians of the galaxy but in the end
he could also choose to take a
completely different path in the comics
he ultimately joins the guardians to
protect the universe and to rebuild it
after a terrible catastrophe that this
becomes a reality at the end of the
movie is actually quite realistic it's
clear that the guardians will regroup
and as gunn said not everyone
necessarily has to survive that leaves
us with a question who might die
the most likely scenario for us is the
death of drax the actor has recently
fallen out with disney and has long
announced that this will be his final
marvel film well that makes it very easy
to simply let the character die however
other deaths cannot be excluded for
instance peter could sacrifice himself
for gamora if she were to be in danger
again also the possibility of rocket
dying cannot be ruled out indeed james
gunn recently stated that he put all of
himself into the role of rocket and thus
with his departure from the franchise
his character dies as well no matter who
or whether someone even dies we'll
surely have tears running down our faces
with the end of guardians of the galaxy
this was our preview of guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. even though not much is
known right now we hope we were able to
give you a decent overview what are your
thoughts who else would you love to see
in the movie or how do you envision the
story let us know in the comments below
and if you liked this video don't forget
to give it a thumbs up see you next time
[Music]
you